i think it was about four years ago when
i first posed the question what is a
woman i had started focusing on the
scourge of gender ideology years before
that and argued against it in a million
different ways
making a million different arguments and
a million words or more and somehow over
those several years it never occurred to
me to ask the most basic question of all
i had heard the phrase trans women are
women
so many times and yet for so long i
never thought to respond what does that
mean what do you think a woman is what
are you trying to say
four years ago for whatever reason it
finally dawned on me i realized i didn't
need a million words only four what is a
woman
now once i realized that this is the
question really the only question we
need to ask the question that pulls down
the whole edifice of gender ideology
i started asking it and asking it more
asking it over and over again
i asked it for years on social media in
speeches and interviews
it was clear that the proponents of
gender ideology the architects of the
current madness which is gripping our
society we're not going to answer the
question because they can't
and they had elected instead to simply
ignore me which was easy enough
so i reached a point where i realized
that either
i could keep shouting into the abyss
it's definitely an option i do it all
the time or simply give it up and move
on with my life that i can't do i can't
really give anything up or i could take
drastic action
and i chose the latter option
if they wouldn't answer my question i
decided that i would force their hand
and so i hatched an elaborate scheme
that over the past year has taken me
across the globe and got me into the
room with
some of the leading quote-unquote
experts in the field i talked to
politicians academics pediatricians
psychiatrists
trans activists surgeons and many many
more i went everywhere from
san francisco to the african wilderness
and yes i did all of this essentially
because nobody on the left would respond
to my tweet
an overreaction perhaps
but i don't believe in proportional
responses as you've probably noticed by
now i've had to keep this project secret
for a year finally we we can announce it
though we announced it today and there's
still so much that i can't say and that
will will be revealed in the near future
uh we'll have a full trailer for it in
the coming weeks but for now here's a
very quick
sneak peek watch
i have traveled all over the world
for the past year
asking one simple question
what is
a woman
what is a woman what is it what is it i
don't know
people are laughing is that is that a
dumb question
i've been asking everybody this and
almost nobody can answer it what is a
woman what is a woman that's a great
question
[Music]
if one person can tell me what a woman
is
congressman thank you for for being here
i think this interview is over let's
turn off the cameras i just wanted to
know what is a woman
it's not a complicated question
now that um
that congressman very much regretted
inviting me to uh his office for a
sit-down he was
you know not the only interview subject
to regret their life decisions i can
tell you that but i can't tell you much
more than that um when it comes to
specific specifics but but i can tell
you
that all i did
was ask the most basic questions um if
gender ideology was going to collapse on
camera
and it did in spectacular fashion
i wanted it to collapse under the weight
of its own incoherence i wanted the
allegedly smart highly credentialed
advocates of this stuff to just bury
themselves and they did too
one line in scripture that i returned to
in my head over and over again as we
film this project is romans 1 22
professing themselves to be wise they
became fools
i watched the wise make fools of
themselves over and over again
in fact much of the real wisdom that i
did encounter and i encountered some
you'll see that in the film also
came from simple normal people the kinds
of people that the wise would say are
fools
so we ask the question how did the left
get away with propagating these ideas
for so long
while somehow never having to answer
even the most basic questions about it
how did they conquer western society
with an ideology that falls over and
shatters into a thousand pieces with a
simple flick of a finger
it's this enormous
seemingly imposing totally ubiquitous
thing something that has
reshaped our civilization changed the
way people see themselves and their own
species
and yet all you have to do is walk up
and just poke it just just poke it and
it pops like an overinflated balloon
how could something so flimsy
so thin
have so much success
the answer is for one thing people are
scared it has threatened the sane into
silence that was that was something that
became abundantly clear as soon as i set
out on my what is a woman journey
because everywhere we went um almost
everybody that we talked to even the
ones who who knew the truth and were
willing to say it
even then most of them still look kind
of from side to side and whispered like
they were spies passing state secrets
there's a lot of fear out there because
the left is always standing in the
middle of the crowd with a bomb strapped
to its chest
threatening to hit the red button if
anybody dares question them
but what you find so often is that it's
a dummy bomb
strapped to a dummy
people are afraid of a phantom now
it's true that the left owns all the
institutions and so they do have the
power to punish you i myself have
already basically accepted that at least
some of my social media platforms
will not survive the release of this
film i'm already expecting that this
movie is somewhat of a kamikaze mission
in that way
which is why i wanted to get it right
because it might be my my last act who
knows at least on
when it comes to my access to the
internet
um
i know there will probably be some steep
consequences especially considering
the people who we embarrass in this film
and how badly we embarrass them
so the fear people have is not entirely
imaginary
and yet the fear has scared people to
such an extent
that they think they can't even talk
about this at all they treat the subject
the subject of what a woman is what
biological sex is like it's like it's
literally radioactive
the fear causes people to fall silent
and the silence only emboldens the
ideological terrorists even more
the second factor is that the left is
very good and making simple things seem
complicated
not just on this issue but all issues
what they do is they try to drown you in
jargon and buzzwords and caveats and
exceptions to the rule and any other
ball they need to throw at you to
distract you from the topic at hand
soon before you know it you're off the
path you're knee-deep in the weeds
can't remember where you were going or
why or what you were talking about
and then
when you're out there
in the muck
off the trail confused
they'll come along and say you see this
is all so complicated you should stop
thinking about this subject just leave
it to us
rest your puny little brain child and
let us think for you
trust the experts
what they don't expect is that you'll
take them up on it
and actually go talk to those experts
and ask them the questions they're
supposed to be able to so easily answer
actually ask the questions
you know what by that i mean don't just
sit there and let them talk at you
but ask the questions
apply some skepticism to what they're
telling you just a little bit
that's not what they're expecting
that's exactly what i did
and the results are
tremendous as you'll see soon enough
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated